samsung est de retour avec un nouveau
smartphone pliable samsung galaxy z
folle de catch je vous ai déjà présenté
le jour du test est sortie du samsung
galaxy z flip 4 celui-là smartphone tu
très cool qu'ils se pliaient également
la grosse différence qu'on entre ces
deux modèles c'est que le z flic 4 on
vient réduire l'encombrement avec un
format plus petit dans la poche tandis
que chanteuse est folle de quatre on
vient agrandir la surface utile on a un
plus grand écran est un smartphone qui
sera fatalement un peu plus grand dans
la poche également aussi épais mais qui
par contre en vraiment service de
produits très différents on va
concentrer aujourd'hui sur les épaules
de cap qui est un produit qui est dédié
destiné à la productivité puis surtout
il ya eu des changements autant sur le z
philippe iv versus des flics 3 d'année
dernière pas de changement de design
quelques changements intentions mais pas
au niveau du design fin c'est pas
vraiment ça se remarque pas il ya eu un
peu de couple sur les côtés mais c'est
tout par contre ici il ya un vrai
changement un vrai changement qui même
s'il ne paraît pas significatif qui est
quand même vraiment très intéressant sur
le modèle de 2022 par rapport au modèle
de 2021 aujourd'hui un tour complet du
samsung galaxy z folle 4 on a regardé si
intéressant s'il était pour vous quel
prix quoi comment à tout voir tout
quasiment fin j'espère en tout cas ça va
être très très grand et très intéressant
les prêts honda
[Musique]
je vous parle de formats je vous parle
de design c'est super intéressant il
faut vraiment le mettre en opposition
par rapport au modèle de l'année
dernière à savoir que regarder sur le z
fold 4 les noms c'est compliqué cette
folle de 4,2 cette année les épaules de
3,2 l'année dernière quand on les
regarde comme ça en duo je pourrais ça
ne paraît pas évident je vous assure
qu'il ya un vrai changement en fait si
vous les mettez comme ça c'est être un
petit peu plus évident à savoir que le
modèle de l'année dernière était un peu
plus haut donc celui là est un peu moins
haut que la honda un peu moins de
hauteur par rapport à ce modèle là mais
la grosse différence qui vient aussi
s'opérer c'est que ce modèle là était un
peu moins large que le modèle de cette
année donc ce qu'ils ont fait entre les
aides folle trois lots est folle de
quatre ils sont venus légèrement
diminuer la hauteur et augmenter un peu
la largeur et vous voyez c'est ça me
paraît assez évident regarder le dites
moi si vous le voyez vous en commentaire
prenez un peu de temps jeter un oeil ça
change très légèrement le format on
reste sur la même chose attendait ça
smartphone qui vient supplier avec une
pays hors d'air tikal ça reste la même
chose mais on vient adapté par rapport
au retour des consommateurs dont vous
voyez c'est vachement bien de faire vos
retours et c'est ça qui est intéressant
alors c'est pas que les eaux autour des
consommateurs de la chaîne attention
soins aux frais clairette succès les
retours du monde entier des clients des
consommateurs des médias de tout le
monde du monde entier et c'est vachement
intéressant parce que voyez ça permet
d'influer sur des fabricants sur des
industriels pour venir changer des
produits pour venir les faire évoluer
donc le format est un peu différent est
tant mieux on ne sent la gauche ici le
galaxy z folle de quatre dernières d'un
à génération ici c'est le zèle fold 3 ça
c'est la génération 2000 21 ans
christina 2021-2022 l'ancien le nouveau
je vous ai mis exactement le même
extrait au même moment du même film ça
illustre vraiment cette différence de
taille parce que pas si vous avez bien
bien vous en rendre compte comme ça on
va essayer de faire pour le mieux mais
en fait le z folle 4 il est un peu plus
large et un peu moins haut par rapport à
celui là si vous regardez aux est folle
de 3 est ce que ça nous fait en réalité
eh bien ça vient nous augmenter les
bordures noires sur le haut qu'on a ici
voyez ici j'ai un peu plus de bordures
sur le modèle 4 que sur le modèle 3 je
le vois également lorsque je viens zoom
est comme ça c'est un peu plus clair
parce que regarder il me manque un peu
plus d'informations ici sur la main que
je n'en avais ici alors on va pas venir
nous met autant parce que c'est beaucoup
par rapport au format mais on voit
vraiment la différence à se situe ici
voyez moment qu'un petit bout ici là que
je vais retrouver ici au niveau de l'os
l'âge et palau cela gelos et puis autre
truc qui est intéressant je sais pas si
vous le voyez réellement c'est que la
densité de pixels a été améliorée au
niveau de la caméra sous l'écran j'ai
vraiment les mettre côte à côte pour
vous puissiez vous en rendre compte ça
se situe réellement juste ici regardez
on voit davantage sur le modèle 3 la
caméra qui est sous l'écran justice il a
brillé au niveau de mon pointer tandis
que sur l'autre modèle le modèle 4 on la
voit un petit peu moins et plus discrète
c'est beaucoup plus léger alors bon
c'est vrai comme ça à travers une caméra
ce n'était pas hyper hyper évident pour
vous mais je peux vous assurer qu'à
l'onu je vois davantage sur le modèle 3
les petits pixels qui sont là et qui
sont déjà oublié ce qu'est déjà quand
même plutôt bien j'ai été doublé je
penche la densité de pixels et là je le
vois quand même beaucoup moins alors je
le vois un peu à l'oeil nu lorsque je
vais le regarder mais sinon je puis vous
assurer que ça se voit quand même
beaucoup moins donc ça c'est vraiment un
gros bénéfices au niveau de la densité
de pixels pour le coup cette caméra sous
l'écran elle vient davantage joué son
rôle à se rendre invisible versus le
modèle de l'année dernière autre
illustration de sa différence allait
venir la retrouver ici notamment dans
les paramètres c'est aussi intéressant
parce que regarder vous le voyez ici
comme il est un peu moins haut et bien
je dis affiché un peu moins de choses
j'ai quelques petits éléments plus que
je retrouve sur le modèle de l'année
dernière par rapport au modèle de cette
année par contre et là je le vois
également je viens affiche est
légèrement plus sur le côté j'ai un peu
de blanc voyez mon cadre est
complètement terminée tandis que là ils
venaient complètement se frotter à
l'orge pas si c'est regarder très clair
là voyez c'est le z fil 4g vraiment le
contour et j'ai mon nikon qui vient
faire le tour complètement ici tandis
que sur le z flip trois et bientôt je
viens vraiment touché le box sort du
bord dont il ya quand même cette petite
différence ici et c'est assez notable
alors c'est du petit point de détail
attention ils n'ont pas non plus
complètement révolutionné leur format
mais c'est vrai que sur certains usagers
je pense notamment aux usages liés à la
productivité ça permet peut-être d'avoir
des choses un peu plus large devant un
peu plus d'informations je n'y a pas
vraiment pas grand chose ici mais malgré
tout ils sont venus travailler ça alors
autres trucs qui sont dû travailler et
vous êtes être le voir vous avez un
petit peu moins de bordures ici sur le
modèle 4 versus le modèle 3 un petit peu
on se parle vraiment de pas grand chose
un petit poêle 2 voyez ce que je veux
dire pas grand chose c'est la même chose
sur l'écran externe est aussi un travail
forcément parce que le format global
change donc saâdia s'impliquer sur
l'écran externe ça ces modèles de 2021
modèles de 2 22 déjà ce que j'aime
beaucoup mieux c'est qu'on a moins sept
espèces de grandes barres auriez cette
grande partie la noix au centre qui
était pas où on avait la sensation que
l'écran est un peu refoulé sur la droite
et je trouvais ça un peu dommage bon
maintenant que je vois là je me rends
compte davantage mais c'est vrai que ça
a fonctionné déjà pas trop mal comme ça
on voit qu'effectivement il est un peu
moins haut donc on a moins cette
sensation de hauteur on est un petit peu
plus étroit et on est un poil plus large
au niveau de l'écran alors pour autant
ils ont fait un boulot c'est à dire
qu'ils sont venues réduire toute cette
partie là là toute cette grande partie
noire au niveau de la charnière pour
venir re centre un petit peu l'écran est
ce que c'est vraiment pas mal ça nous
apporte quoi et bien la même chose que
ce qu'on voyait tout à l'heure à savoir
que et bien là on va avoir le petit côté
à côté de mon cadre rose veut avoir une
petite bande blanche qui vient
s'afficher alors qu'avant je n'avais pas
du tout il était vraiment refoulés à
droite alors d'un point de vue sauf
qu'ils ont aussi fait un truc c'est que
sur le banc sais pas pourquoi c'était
deux coups du soft ça j'ai un peu plus d
espace en dessous de mon menu qu'avant
moi je l'avais pas j'arrive est vraiment
en bas donc bon ça c'est uniquement du
software mais vous voyez il ya quand
même une différence que c'est beaucoup
plus intéressant est beaucoup mieux
intégrer ce qu'on a sur le modèle 4 par
rapport au modèle 3 une fois de plus ça
reste des réglages qui sont extrêmement
fins mais là pour le coup je trouve que
visuellement esthétiquement c'est pas
mal alors après moi ici sur le modèle de
l'année dernière j'avais un cadre tout
noirs ici là j'ai un cap qui est un peu
plus argentés donc ça faisait un côté un
peu plus masquer que je n'ai pas
réellement ici mais ce que je vois quand
même c'est que toute cette petite partie
la voyez qu'ils étaient rationnés je
vais les mettre dos à dos pour vous
voyez vraiment là toute cette partie là
là qui était assez épaisse eh bien je
l'est plus donc j'ai effectivement le
contournement d'écran qui est juste là
mais pour autant cette partie là elle a
été réduite on est de réduire
l'encombrement ça peut paraître tout con
comme ça mais c'est vraiment des choix
industriels qui ont été faits il a fallu
venir travailler complètement pour
arriver à des choses comme ça et qui
malgré tout et on le voit plus comme ça
en prenant un peu de hauteur c'est
vachement moins masse voyez ça versus ça
ça peut paraître tout con mais vraiment
s'améliore significativement le produit
le truc qui assez marrant c'est que bien
combien modifier un peu les tailles
d'une génération à l'autre on regarde
exactement les mêmes diagonale d'écran à
l'intérieur vous avez un écran d'une
diagonale de 7,6 pouces et à l'extérieur
c'est du 6,2 pouces exactement la même
chose sauf que ce sont les résolutions
qui change sur le nouveau modèle vous
avez une résolution intérieur de 2 1176
par 1812 pixels versus 2208 pas 1768
voyez qu'ici il ya quand même un
changement bien couvrir la même
diagonale n'y a pas la même proportion
s'est pas réparties de la même manière à
quelques pixels près la même chose sur
l'écran intérieur sur le nouveau modèle
vous êtes à 2316 par 904 2316 904 en
escales bâtisseurs du 2268 par 832 une
fois de plus pas grand chose mais malgré
tout ça a son importance du changement
il y en a ici en bas rhin corning
gorilla glass victis plus donc meilleure
protection avec de l'aluminium armor on
va voir aussi un processeur plus
performant le snapdragon 8 + jane 1 12
giga de ram clp ddr5 et on va voir 256
512 ou carrément un terrain de stockage
par contre le tarif reste le même on
commence par ont commencé le modèle de
la dernière forcément à changer et à
baisser mais le tarif de base est le
même
1799 euros saâd un certain prix un
certain budget mais c'est vraiment un
produit qui est destiné plus aux
professionnels aux technophiles et en
tout cas à ceux pour les moyens de
mettre 1799 euros dans un smartphone
avec de belles innovations la taille de
la batterie reste inchangé par contre là
où ça vient changer c'est à l'arrière au
niveau du module photo ça c'est un truc
qui n'allait pas l'année dernière à
savoir qu'eux on avez un smartphone très
cher mais la fiche technique était en
deçà par rapport à la gamme photo la
gamme ss-21 l'année dernière tandis que
cette année ils sont vraiment venus
améliorer la copie alors on garde le
même design a le même look and feel au
niveau du module photo complètement
adapté bien évidemment à ce nouveau
smartphone mais ça reste la même chose
esthétiquement par contre on a amélioré
les capteurs on un capteur grand-angle
de 50 méga pixels un ultra grand-angle
des 12 mégapixels et un tel objectif de
10 mégapixels déjà mieux que ce qu'on
avait avant on a toujours la petite
caméra de celle fille qui est ici et
vous avez toujours votre caméra qui est
planqué sous l'écran qui a ici et je
monte le résultat regard des résultats
pour moi c'est en outre un grand oui
vous allez voir on va aller jusqu'au
bout s'est fait une petite balade dans
paris comme ça on est relativement pas
mal je me cherchais des scènes un peu
compliqué les scènes un peu merdique et
il s'en sort vachement bien place de la
bastille grand angle ultra grand angle
ça va bien on a bien les détails sur
l'arbre n'est quand même pas mal alors
après vous le savez sur 1 du trader en
tant que c'est toute la partie centrale
qui va être meilleur tout l'extérieur là
ça va se dégrader fatalement mais bon le
taf reste fait et il reste quand même
vraiment correct on peut venir nous mais
on un jour ma petite x 3 et on va
jusqu'à x 30 numérique alors pour autant
faut-il aller jusqu'à 30 numérique
réponse est non mais là comme il est là
le boulot est vraiment de très bonne
qualité grand angle on se rapproche on
zoome bon on peut son envie de s'amuser
mois à venir éviter pareil ici regardez
les photos on voit bien le ciel qualité
est là le petit pigeon qui sait dans sa
danse est un art devant pareil je vous
ai fait quelques petits zoomer sur
d'aller voir mais bon c'est vraiment
histoire d'aller voir m veulent tester
alors je me cherchais des scènes un peu
relou avec le soleil en pleine phase
pour voir comment est ce qu ils gérer ça
et ça j'avais vu vous avez vu tout au
long du process de test et vous le
verrez notamment sur les photos nues
c'est vraiment très très impressionnant
on a bien toute la façade du bâtiment
alors forcément on a le soleil est là
donc on a un côté qui est un peu plus
voilé mais malgré tout on a bien tous
les détails de tous les côtés on voit
bien l'arbre et on voit bien les
feuilles ici le ciel bleu et bleu le
soleil est là on a les nuages rien et
cramer tout est maîtrisé et là on va que
la lgo fonctionne vachement bien pareil
sur l'ultra grand angle on a bien la
façade du bâtiment c'est très joli parce
que là on a vraiment les rayons du
soleil est ce que ça super super canon
et pour autant rien n'est cramer et ça
marche juste super bien alors on peut
venir ou non un peu le soleil manga
éviter surtout pour voir ici que même
sur le téléobjectif
le boulot est fait et quand même
vachement bien fait j'ai décalé un peu
sur le côté pour qu'on se rende bien
compte voyez il n'y a pas de pertes
c'est très très cool il photo à la
verticale comme ça pareil de façon ultra
grand-angle jacut par le soleil alors
j'ai bien les rayons là forcément il ya
un moyen peu des limites retourné sur le
côté de l'utra grand-angle mais bon le
boulot est fait pareil ici on a bien la
façade on a bien le ciel bleu pour moi
c'est vraiment très très utilisés sont
ultra grand-angle également la même
chose téléobjectif c'est la même chose
là j'ai le soleil dans le dos on vient
éclairer l'entrée de la place des vosges
ce qui est intéressant c'est que voyez
on récupère sous l'arche ici et bien le
soleil de l'autre côté dans le parc au
niveau de la place des vosges et c'est
très clair c'est bien c'est maîtrisé on
voit bien une personne à qui rendre dans
l'ombre on voit bien ses bras et donc
bull aussi est vachement bien fait pour
me réadapter complètement l'exposition
en fonction de la scène qu'on va avoir
et c'est tout le boulot justement
logiciel qui est fait qui est maîtrisée
ici bon je ne vous mets un peu plus ok
pareil ici ça fonctionne clash repassé
sous l'arche je me suis mis de l'autre
côté je suis venu ajouté cette façade
qui n'est pas éclairée par le soleil
avec un côté qui est très éclairée par
le soleil de l'autre côté et ce qui est
vachement intéressant c'est que voyez ma
façade on la voit bien elle est
préservée j'ai des détails je vois bien
place des vosges doit les gens voient
bien des pierres ici je vois ici qu elle
même un interphone tout est très clair
je vois bien mon panneau est ici toute
cette scène là et très bien exposé
également je vois les gens réels et
cramer semaine un petit ciel les nuages
donc plutôt bien fichu honnêtement je
lui montait un peu le cadre c'est pareil
ça fonctionne sur une ultra grand-angle
et bien c'est pareil voyage et bien le
détail de ma scène j'ai toujours mon
interphone ici je veux toujours bien les
pierres ici également donc le boulot est
plutôt bien fait et lorsque je viens d'y
mener avec monthey l'objectif est bien
de la même manière je vois bien ici tout
mais bricq tout mais pierre de tous les
côtés et la scène ici qui est très
éclairé reste très clair très lisible
donc tout extrêmement bien exposé tous
les côtés donc ça c'est cool pareil on
vient monte alors j'ai fait le test sur
un côté de bâtiments ou là je suis un
peu plus éclairés et là je ne le suis
pas et bien de la même manière ça
fonctionne bien mon nuage et l'a reçue
il a morflé un peu mais pascal soleil
directement non c'est normal mais ça
fonctionne sur l'ultra grand temps je
dirais exactement la même chose j'adore
cette place parce qu'elle est un peu
complexe à bien shooter parce qu'on va
avoir de l'ombre du soleil donne à des
puits lumière avec le soleil très dur en
plus ce moment et je suis venu shooter
et pour autant je vois bien les feuilles
là lorsque j'ai dû soleil j'ai également
mes feuilles j'ai bien mon sol la voyez
avec ses petites plus loin de qui
viennent des puits de lumière au dessus
j'ai bien ma celle qui est bien exposé
ici au fond ou là pour le coup d'oeil
j'ai pas d'arbre donc j'ai le soleil en
plein dessus et je vois bien les gens
qui sont opposés j'ai bien des détails
sur le tronc qui à l'ombre la la même
chose ici avec ma mousse qui est un peu
plus exposées avec le soleil donc non ça
marche et ça marche vraiment bien même
chose sur l' ultra grand-angle et on
peut venir zoom également la même année
alors la caméra de cellfish venu à
chercher un peu sur le même principe
désolé je n'ai pas vu la poubelle sur le
côté c'est pas terrible et bien moi je
suis vraiment dans l'ombre et derrière
c'est très très exposés c'est très fort
avec le soleil alors il va faire tout ce
boulot ou la qualité soit un peu moins
belle parce que c'est une caméra de
celle fille déjà et la qualité un peu
moins bonne mais trouve que dans
l'ensemble c'est pas mal c'est pas
mauvais c'est pas aussi bon que si
j'avais pris mon smartphone et si je
l'avais ouvert si je venais active et ma
caméra là éclats je me voyais auquel cas
je viendrai prendre une photo comme ça
et là ça serait quand même la meilleure
qualité j'ai vraiment voulu tester cette
caméra de sa fille donc on l'a comme ça
l'appareil mais sous un angle différent
alors voyez là j'ai un beau soleil sur
la tronche me suis pas cramé pour autant
le visage est correctement exposées dans
la mesure où on arrive à le faire la
caméra de celle fille a pas non plus une
magie mais ça fonctionne donc on arrive
à le faire on voit bien les scènes
derrière on a bien autre puis lumière
également on voit bien les faits graves
tout est là et tout reste maîtrisée il
ya connaître plus grand temps que l'on
peut prendre un peu de recul voyez comme
ça mais bon voilà c'est que du soft
parce que ces mêmes capteurs exactement
là j'ai avancé et je me suis mis en
plein soleil alors ça sera mieux au
niveau de mon visage pendant tout le
reste devient noir et là ça devient un
peu plus compliqué mais ça ne surprend
pas assez l'optique c'est la photo ça
fonctionne la voyez derrière c'est tout
de suite beaucoup plus joli bon il ya
quand même eu un monde entre ça et ça
mais c'est juste un pas devant mais on
peut le faire et c'est pas des cônes
angers tente être aussi un peu plus
proche alors ici il n'ya pas de macro
mais je me suis juste un peu rapproché
je les fais comme ça est bon on peut
venir faire des choses si on souhaite
l'âge et tenter des trucs un petit peu
plus mais je vraiment venu chercher le
bazar en fait un jeu collectif en arbre
avec daria la place oui en fait c'est la
même chose que ça sauf que là j'avais
fait le point sur la balle j'ai fait le
point sur la place étant très proches ça
ne marche pas bon c'est un peu les
limites du truc mais personne à faire
des photos comme ça c'est vraiment
histoire venir chercher un peu le bazar
alors là j'ai fait quelques photos en
mode portrait j'ai mangé un peu trop de
glace cet été faute ans à faire gaffe
sinon ça fonctionne quoi briller je
trouve que c'est quand même une fois
plutôt bien et là je vais vous le
montrer en vidéo aurait truqué vachement
intéressant c'est tout l'intérêt
justement hop c'est celui-là de ce mode
flex lorsqu'on vient faire des photos et
c'est là que ça devient pertinent que ça
devient intéressant
regardez ça sert vraiment à ça en fait
le mode flex je voulais faire une photo
vous avez votre équipe sur le moniteur
qui est juste là et là vous voyez en
fait ce que vous faites donc je le vois
légèrement je me mets sur le côté comme
ça je vais maintenant je vois qu'elle
fait la photo voilà la photo et shooter
ensuite je peux venir sur mon smartphone
est là comme il est pliée en deux je
vois les photos dont je vois que j'ai
fait que celle là ça je vous montrais
c'est que j'ai fait tout à l'heure avec
juste moi au centre qui suit en couleurs
la gelée en grand donc ça c'est un truc
est vraiment pratique un pour le mode
flex a vraiment au sens de voir les
choses comme ça comme vous déclenchez
directement la main vous pouvez utiliser
les capteurs arrière pour me refaire
toutes les photos vous voulez de bonne
qualité et ça c'est cool alors après
faut faire gaffe vous le posez parce que
la voyez typiquement ces espèces
de tous une très granuleux ces risques
monique et l'écran parce que si je le
pose ils ont utilisé et bien cette phase
là ça veut dire que je le pose sur
l'écran faut pas que ça braille l'écran
ça c'est peut-être le truc qui est un
peu les limites à la verticale pour ce
mode là ça ira mais coucher un peu moins
je continue avec la caméra de celle
filles en différents endroits et brew
voilà ça reste fonctionnel ça convient
c'est plutôt pas mal caméra c'est le
flou sur les caméras longue c'est
exactement la même chose qu'on a vu sur
la place des vols de quelques instants
alors ça c'est la caméra qui à
l'intérieur du smartphone c'est la
caméra que vous avez ici la caméra qui
est planqué sous l'écran alors j'ai
envie de dire non on ne va pas faire de
photos avec ça si vraiment vous avez
l'ouvrir et que vous avez besoin d'une
caméra et bien vous pouvez bien le faire
mais voyez on a une peau qui est qui et
des dieux on a l'impression de voir des
lignes presque c'est pas beau donc vous
pouvez faire effet des images mais elle
fait des images un peu dans l'ambiance
de 2000 a envoyé avec un capteur de 2001
donc non c'est pas beau on est vite et
voilà le rendu est juste pas alors la
photo de nuit elle intéressante à la
fois tony je vous explique ce que j'ai
trouvé vraiment vraiment intéressant
avec cette photo de nuit c'est qu'en
fait et je le voyais en direct et ça
c'est tout ce qui m'intéresse le plus
c'est que on voit le smartphone adapté
lorsque j'ai pris cette photo je voyais
que mes lumières et j'en prenais plein
la gueule c'était pas le ciel on le
voyait un peu moins bien alors on verra
sur une photo de tyler est dès lors que
la lgo a travaillé pendant peut-être une
seconde qu'on voit que la luminosité au
niveau des lampadaires diminué on a ça
qui sort donc le travail vous le voyez
fait sous vos yeux en direct et je
trouve ça bien et le résultat sur le
fichier tel qu'il est là sur mon ordi la
qualité super bonne donc ça fonctionne
vachement bien pareil la voyez la
lumière elle est maîtrisée j'ai pas un
truc avec un halo autour c'est propre
c'est clair c'est net ça marche bien
pareil je cherchais des scènes un peu un
peu compliqué avec des boutiques qui
viennent un peu exposé fort avec des
zones d'ombrés avec une place il ya peu
plus équilibré mais on n'est pas en
plein jour mais voyez on voit tout on
voit ça on voit là on voit bien la voûte
qui est plus éclairer un peu moins
éclairés en voit tout et imax vachement
bien ce smartphone dont toutes les
conditions je trouve très très bon
pareil la nuit place des vosges lors on
a moins si halo de lumière parce qu'on
n'a pas forcément le le soleil mais on a
par contre la rue qui est beaucoup plus
éclairé on voit bien les feuilles dans
l'ombre là on a bien la place qui est
davantage éclairé la et la même manière
qu'en plein jour pour cent bien tout est
maîtrisé il n'y a rien été surexposés on
voit les étoiles dans le ciel on a les
feuilles qui sont mieux exposer sa
marche seul truc qu'on voit et c'est que
des fois c'est un peu trop saturé c'est
une signature du maire je samsung il n'y
a pas d'herbe là et pour autant j'ai
l'impression qu'elle lève alors il n'y a
pas d'air non pas du tout c'est de la
terre comme ça ici mais bon voilà ils
viennent un peu trop saturé et et ça
ressort comme ça des fois c'est un peu
trop poussif aussi la nuit pour essayer
de sortir des éléments dans le ciel ces
trucs qui est des fois un peu moins bien
mais il ya un côté un peu marre envoyé
que tous ces nuages qui viennent de
ressortir comme ça je vous dis une fois
de plus les petits défauts et bien c'est
qu'ici bien c'est de la terre c'est pas
du tout de l'herbe lui lagraula libre ou
bats pour moi ça va être de l'herbe un
don vous voyez même la fontaine est un
peu trop verte voilà ça c'est un peu les
limites du truc mais sinon résultat est
quand même de bonne qualité pareil ici
on revoit bien d'autres interphone alors
que c'est la nuit on voit bien la rue
qui beaucoup mieux exposées derrière une
mieux éclairer dans l'ensemble ça marche
et moi je trouve qu'il est bien alors la
voyez c'est un peu plus dur au niveau de
la lumière je ne voyais que ça foutait
un peu le bazar lorsque j'étais en train
de chuter mais vont voir cette lumière
est un petit peu un petit peu trop forte
ça je me suis décalé sur le côté mais
voilà le boulot est vraiment bien fait
pareil de la même manière c'était
vachement intéressant cette semaine
parce que lorsque je l'ajouté je voyais
qu'il y avait des gros halo de lumière
là je voyais que là aussi c'est un peu
fort et au bout de deux trois secondes
c'est devenu maîtrisé voilà donc non
superbe appareil photo très bien
maîtrisé très beau boulot de samsung
là-dessus et c'est bien qu'il soit venu
complètement améliorer la copie parce
que sur le modèle de l'année dernière on
avait un appareil photo qui était bien
mais pas à la hauteur d'un smartphone a
quasiment 1800 balle là pour le coup on
en appareil photo qui est vraiment bien
et même sur un smartphone à 1800 ballon
n'a pas de honte à sortir son appareil à
voir des photos donc ça c'est très cool
bravo samsung a déjà je vous montre sur
la caméra arrière km un principal je
filme en nuage des en 30 images par
seconde j'ai profité de la stable à bien
me balader d'un côté de l'autre je peux
changer hop là je passe sur lui très
grand-angle et là sur le tel objectif
oula ça c'est un petit peu violent
regarder l'heure et c'est beaucoup plus
clair et objectif et a tout de suite
beaucoup plus de vols donc les
transitions seront un peu
l'ange blond ce noyau comme ça ça semble
aller encore cogne pas trop mal à quatre
cailloux à jeter sur la caméra avant
l'art 30 images par seconde ce qui peut
lui tenir la main comme ça baladée y
regarder d'un côté venir regarder
l'autre et ça c'est la caméra à
l'intérieur c'est que du full hd on
dirait qu'un voile on a vraiment une
résolution horrible et là vraiment c'est
la caméra qui est là pour être là mais
qui globalement ça pas grand chose autre
qui est bien au niveau de l'interface au
niveau de la photo c'est vous avez quand
même pas mal de possibilités vous notez
quand même que vous avez trois caméras
l'arrière une caméra à l'intérieur même
si elle n'est pas terrible et une caméra
à l'extérieur est en fait vous avez
différents modes qui sont vachement bien
deux par justement le fait qu'ils
puissent venir se plier je vous le
disais les meilleures caméras sont les
caméras qu'on a ici mais pour autant on
a un écran noir donc vous venez allumez
votre écran vous venez appuyer là en
appuyant là vous activer un aperçu et là
vous dites ok je vais venir faire une
photo alors soit vous appuyer
directement sur le bouton de volume et
ça fait une photo soit ça marche bien
vous mettez votre main la salle art
connaît ça déclenche directement et truc
qui est cool c'est que comme on est sur
un truc qui se plaît ça c'est pareil
c'est que du logiciel et bien vous
retrouvé vos photos directement sur le
côté ou alors j'ai une vraie tronche des
grands jeux dessus c'est absolument
dingue mais voyez vous les retrouvez
donc ça c'est assez marrant comme il se
plie il ya vous pouvez le prendre à elle
posé comme je vous ai manqué tout à
l'heure dans le cadre de la vidéo donc
c'est un peu tout l'intérêt d'avoir un
smartphone qui vient supplier qui vous
apporte les fonctionnalités la côte et
gaming experience aussi est vachement
bien alors ici je vous sors un petit
tassement neuf jeux que j'affectionne
tout particulièrement ici ce qui est
bien c'est que le jeu est complètement
adapté au format du smartphone ça c'est
cool et si on profite vraiment de ce
très grand écran et puis cette petite
caméra une fois de plus ce qui se fait
quand même vachement mieux oublier que
celle que la génération précédente donc
en termes de gaming ont un smartphone
qui est puissant on a un smartphone qui
est très cool et pure et surtout des
jeux qui seront adaptés en tout cas ici
c'est le cas donc ça c'est bien autre
nouveauté qu'on a cette année versus
année dernier alors déjà comme on a un
écran qui est un peu plus large on vient
de profiter de six icônes en va versus 5
dès le départ ici alors qu'on est
forcément un peu plus serré mais surtout
la nouveauté qui vachement intéressante
c'est cette barre des tâches alors la
barre des tâches et elle est assez
marrante voyez par exemple je viens ici
et l'année dernière j'avais rien c'est à
dire que comme sur tous les smartphones
je me retrouvais avec la partie en bas
je peux venir un scroll et je peux le
dire essayer ça l'ac thann est ce enfin
un truc qui est vraiment différent alors
on l'aura sur le z folle de 3 puisque
c'est que du logiciel il y aura une mise
à jour qui viendra les trucs qui est
marrant c'est de se dire comme on est
sur un produit dédié à la productivité
on veut pouvoir avoir les dernières
applications ouvertes directement juste
en bas et puis là un petit menu qui vous
permet d'arriver à toutes vos
applications comme c'est de la
productivité on veut pouvoir faire du
multitâche très rapidement on veut
pouvoir changer les choses très
rapidement et ça c'est assez malin parce
qu'en fait regardez par exemple j'en
sais rien moi je vais me prendre mon
application message je veux venir la
mettre en bas je veux dire la met à
droite et bien cela prend je la fait
glisser gelé tout le temps directement
ici sous les yeux ces pratiques la même
manière je prends mon application note
prends mon application note et je peux
bien la mettre d'un côté au milieu je
peux la mettre ici elle est par exemple
l'âge lamela donc là je peux lire
affaire à des notes très très facilement
et j'en sais rien moi je veux prendre
mon petit appareil photo je vais venir
le positionner au milieu parce qu'en
plus je veux bien faire quelques petites
photos en fait ce qui est cool c'est que
je peux faire du multitâche avec quatre
choses ouvertes en même temps alors il
faut que ça y est insensé que ce soit
pratique voyez pas ce que ça typiquement
c'est rigolo mais je peux venir le
décaler un peu là donc là je peux venir
à voir mes collections je peux venir à
bosser je peux venir regarder des emails
peut mettre une petite série si je veux
comme cela en truck flottant parce que
j'adore mme bouvier le cerveau avec
plein d'image plutôt qu'en même temps de
notre côté je vais pouvoir envoyer des
messages tout et je vais pouvoir prendre
des notes griffonnées travail et je veux
faire plein de choses et je peux le
faire donc ça c'est pas mal et ce qui
est cool c'est qu'après je me dis ok
j'ai vu tout ça et bien j'en sais rien
moi je veux aller par exemple passer un
coup de fil et d'un jeu cliquer là haut
up j'arrive dans mon application l'a
directement qui ça j'en ai marre je le
veux plus et bien hop je viens ici je le
supprime et c'est très réactif je peux
venir changer très rapidement j'appuie
ça change ça va vite ça bouge et le fait
d'avoir ça comme ça directement et bien
sous la main je trouve ça assez marrant
donc ça c'est plutôt chouette alors
ensuite on à l'application notes comme
on a le s pen c'est le respect folle
edition tel qu'on l'a vu l'année
dernière 49 euros s'il vous intéresse
venez tous les liens en bas dans la
description et bien je peux venir
dessiner griffonnés de la même manière
prendre des notes avec différents
niveaux d'appuis avec des mines que je
peux venir changer donc ça c'est pareil
je sais pas si vous vous êtes un glyphe
honneur et un décideur mais si vous
voulez vous pouviez le faire tout en
sachant que ce espen fonctionnant sur
l'écran intérieure mais ne fonctionne
pas sur un écran extérieur sur l'écran
extérieur le s pen volaille il est plus
la difficulté on a plus besoin donc
c'est vraiment pour toute la partie
intérieure mettant de côté un peu
négatif et six de ses space et qui n'est
rien pour rien arrangé par rapport à la
gamme galaxy note avant je pouvais bien
rangé directement dedans pour autant il
existe des coques et des accessoires que
nous présente samsung où je peux venir
l'inclure dedans donc bon pourquoi pas
je sais pas d'ailleurs si vous vous êtes
un utilisateur du splc un truc qui vous
intéresse ou pas moi je trouve ça
marrant mais c'est parce que j'utilise
donc je le prends dans ce cadre là je
regarde griffonne jedessine mais je
comprends qu'il est plein de gens qui
veulent le faire et je pense notamment à
des chefs d'entreprise qui veulent par
exemple ou des businessman des
commerciaux des gens qui ont besoin de
venir dessiner prendre de notes rapides
et qui est un clavier n'est pas tout la
chose la plus aisée on veut pouvoir
faire comme ça vous noterez quand même
et c'est intéressant que sur cette
partie là et bien sûr l'écran extérieur
il n'y a pas de barre des tâches c'est
vraiment que pour l'intérieur ce qui me
paraît pas déconner ce qu'il paraît pas
surprenant ici donc ça ça fonctionne je
trouve ça marrant fait cette barre des
tâches voyez là alors après quand on va
bien bouger elle va venir disparaître
vous avez qu à venir bouger et elle
reviendra joue pas je trouve ça assez
rigolo je ne sais pas s'il ya un usage
pour vous cet autre qui vous plairait ou
pas mais moi je trouve ça pas mal parce
qu'une fois de plus on s'inscrit dans
l'idée de la productivité et c'est un
téléphone qui est là pour la
productivité donc bon ça aussi ça me
convient entre ce qui a été améliorée
c'est une nouveauté logiciel donc vous
l'aurez sur le z folle de 3com sur les
épaules de 4 c'est toute la gestion des
réseaux sociaux et notamment d'instagram
instagram lorsque vous l'ouvrier
normalement c'était ça c'était ça et
c'était pas terrible ils ont venu
rajouter une petite flèche alors si vous
voulez mettre instagram ici ou si vous
ici pour moi ça n'a aucun intérêt mais
vous pouvez venir le faire par contre
ils ont fait un truc est pas mal quand
vous allez dans vos paramètres vous
allez dans écran et vous allez dans un
truc qui existait déjà l'année dernière
c'est à dire que applications en plein
écran et là vous avez plus de choix et
c'est pas mal fichu vous pouvez choisir
les applications qui seront en plein
écran en 16 9 ou en 4/3 et là vous avez
une liste d'applications qui sont
présents ts qui sont un peu plus grandes
et notamment instagram qui là par défaut
et en 16/9 et que moi je vais venir
mettre en plein écran donc comme ça je
les en plein écran et lorsque je reviens
dans mon instagram un plat qui est juste
là et voilà je suis en plein écran ça ça
me plaît bien parce que c'est une autre
expérience une expérience qui a amélioré
et en fait c'est ça ce qu'avant on avait
un très grand écran mais on avait des
trucs qui était pas complètement adaptée
là ils viennent l'adapter d'un point de
vue software donc ça c'est cool et si
par exemple eh bien je me mets une
petite vidéo bien regardé j'ai ma vidéo
qui adapté également j'en profite donc
ça ça me plaît alors ça vient me bouffe
un bout parce que c'est ce même problème
du format c'est que ça vient de manger
un bout on image en haut ça vient de
manger un bout de mon image en bas donc
c'est pas complètement idéal mais d'un
autre côté on est quand même sur un
format qui est un peu à part donc si on
veut vraiment profiter d'expériences
naturel et normal on reste en 16/9 le
plat d'écran c'est pas mal mais une fois
de plus on vient manger un peu de
contenu pourquoi parce que il n'est pas
créée pourrait transformer la moiti par
exemple ça typiquement les lire il s'ils
sont créés en 9/16 et pas sur un format
carré donc c'est un peu le bazar on perd
de la formation est un peu la limite du
truc c'est un smartphone qui a du wifi 6
e versus le wifi 6 à enerlya donc il est
également wifi six wi fi 6e donc ça
c'est bien parce qu'on a aujourd'hui à
meilleures normes ici on les certifier
résistant à l'eau en ipx8 alors c'est
les éclaboussures attention ce calme
hein c'est pas un 10 points 68 san ip x
huit on a bien évidemment de la 5g bref
c'est un smartphone que je trouve très
jolie dès que faut quand même
relativement cher alors il va venir
chauffer un peu légèrement lorsque vous
allez faire tourner à pas mal de jeu et
si les compagnies dessus mais j'aime
bien ce format continuent à y trouver
bien c'est beaucoup plus niche qu'un
galaxy z flip 4 la gamme z flip qui est
quand même vachement plus grand public
mais pour autant c'est un joli
smartphone c'est un très joli
smartphones et après bien évidemment il
ya toute l'expérience écosystème de
samsung avec le galaxy bunch de pro avec
la watch 5 avec la watch cinq pros ça on
en parle bientôt donc voila moi je
trouve bien alors au terme de tarifs
jamais tarif là j'ai voulu faire ce que
je connais pas par coeur sur la version
256 go on et à 1799 euros sur la version
512 à 1919 euro et sur la version
intégrale des à
2159 euros ça une exclu ça me saoule
points comme le terrain d'ailleurs s'il
vous intéresse on est les liens en bas
dans la description pour aller jeter un
oeil voilà pour ce smartphone moi je le
trouve bien je trouve jolie une
évolution en fait ce qui est intéressant
envoyée c'est que et une fois plus et je
voulais dit au début de la vidéo samsung
a écouté les retours du monde entier
pour venir modifier un peu sa copie pour
plaire davantage et pour marcher
davantage avec les usages les besoins et
je trouve bien je trouve intéressant
c'est pas le smartphone peut être idéal
pour venir regarder du contenu quoi
qu'on puisse en dire parce que on a
malgré tout des grandes bord à droite à
gauche et si on veut venir complètement
l'adapter et bien on voit perdre un peu
de contenu mais l'idée quand bella
l'idée est bonne et si vous voulez un
smartphone qui devient une tablette pour
notamment toutes les questions de
productivité et bien samsung galaxy z
folle 4 dites moi votre avis ce que vous
en pensez est ce qu'il vous plaît vous
ne pouvez pas qu'est ce que vous pensez
des évolutions par rapport à l'année
dernière est ce que vous êtes plutôt
satisfait c'est de vue ou alors
absolument pas marquer ma tout ça bien
évidemment justin baro commentaires on
se retrouve très vite déçu on va
continuer à parler de textes de samsung
mais pas que parce qu'à plein de
nouveautés plein de choses qui arrivent
à s'écouler pitt si vous voulez aller
voir mon test des galaxies et buzz deux
pros et bien vous pouvez aller les voir
aller en ligne également le test du
galaxy à z flip 4 aussi et puis y'a
plein de choses pour ça c'est chouette
allez vous embrasse pour les soins de
vous il ya très vite
[Musique]